we have breaking news tonight about the
house and House Intelligence Committee
investigation into Russia collusion
allegations this comes as the plot
thickens in the special counsel separate
probe here to give us an update as the
top Republican working the house panel
investigation Texas Congressman Mike
Conaway so congressman you are ending
the interview phase here of the House
Intelligence Committee investigation
into Russia's meddling in the election
you've got a draft report out tonight
that you're going to give the Democrats
tomorrow give us the headline what did
you find
well the headlines are that we've we've
reached that point where we've
interviewed all the folks would need to
we've looked at some 3,300 thousand
documents seventy-three interviews that
we've done across the course of the
state trying to answer the four
questions that were originally set out
for a committee to answer yes the
Russians tried to interfere them with
our advice with our election process yes
they had cyber attacks active measures
going on we could find no evidence of
collusion between either campaign and
the Russians and we also have some
recommendations we'll have
recommendations that speak to what we do
or elections going forward how important
it is for Americans to be on guard on a
process it's sacred to our democracy our
represented Republic quite frankly then
that is the electing of leadership
across this country but on that the big
piece of the puzzle that everybody has
been talking about which is one of the
reasons why your investigation was
struck in the first place no collusion
that you found no evidence no evidence
of collusion between the Trump campaign
and the Russians how are the excellent
campaign how confident are you of that
well we've got we found none and so you
never know what you never know but we
found no reason to think that that
there's something we're missing in this
regard we've talked to everybody we
believe we need to talk to and you know
every congressional investigation has
always got a caveat that you know 10
years from now some private diary might
be found that leads to a different
conclusion but we'll address that as a
part of our ongoing constant oversight
responsibilities Putin's not going
anywhere so the Intel committee has
ongoing oversight responsibilities that
will continue but with respect to answer
in these four questions we believe we've
got the information necessary to answer
those for the American people now the
president has been repeatedly tweeting
that if there was collusion it was on
the side of the Clinton campaign with
the Russians so again you found no
evidence
of that either not direct the obviously
the steel dossier steals a British
citizen he talked to some level of
Russians third fourth fifth six hand
whatever is there was done he was paid
by the DNC and in Hillary Clinton
Investigative Committee we don't believe
there was any direct information
provided to the DNC or the Hillary's
campaign that it was a British citizen
there was actually feeding this
information in that may speak to one of
our recommendations and that is campaign
finance disclosure is probably ought to
be a little more fulsome than they
currently are shouldn't be able to hide
with those kinds of activities behind a
lawyers bill that simply says legal fees
associated research or legal fees
associated with compliance so there will
be some recommendations that we think
that will speak to maybe a fuller
disclosures as to where money gets spent
over the course of the investigation
congressman which has been running now
for fourteen months you talked with ten
people on the Trump side of the fence
you talked with ten people on the
Clinton side of the fence think it's the
only person that you didn't get a chance
to talk to was Paul Manafort because he
was indicted before you got a chance to
bring him before the committee based
upon the number of people that you have
talked to the number of documents that
you have looked at and the interim
conclusion that you have come to based
on the evidence at hand do you think
that the Muller investigation could
possibly find anything different than
you did when it comes to collusion
between the Trump campaign in Russia so
John I don't want to I don't want to go
there
we're not having anything to do
whatsoever the mother investigation he's
got separate two separate authorities
and everything else and I hope he does
terrific job of whatever it is he's
doing but we didn't find any evidence of
pollution you know I don't know that he
will either do you do you believe that
you have all the information with
respect to Manta Ford we scheduled him
early on and then our deference to my
colleague or Adam we decided a shift
that we decided was premature
we put off that that interview and then
he gets indicted and it's beyond our
reach at that point in time but yes we
believe we've got the information
necessary to support the conclusions
we've come to you one thing that you
talk about is leaks of information from
the intelligence community saying you
talk about problematic contacts between
senior intelligence community officials
and the media do you think this rises to
the level of criminal
well we don't have the reach to be able
to say that certainly leaks of
classified information are criminal
events if we had found something that we
knew directly was criminal we would be
able to to make a criminal referral in
that regard we were hopeful at the Trump
administration is much more aggressive
in going after leaks because it is
corrosive to our ability to do what we
need to do it could be dangerous it
could get people I know this says a bit
melodramatic but leaks could get people
killed folks that are working on our
behalf and really dangerous spots of the
world we put them at risk when we give
out information that shouldn't be some
release - so we believe there was
contact we've got one specific person
that will show you the report that will
go out that makes that comment there are
some Democrats who are not happy with
the fact that the House Intelligence
Committee is wrapping up its
investigation one of them is a member of
the Senate Judiciary Committee Chris
Coons let's play for you what he said
recently the Senate Intelligence
Committee as you just recognized
continues to make solid progress and the
Special Counsel robert muller continues
to make significant progress I find
those both encouraging but the Senate
Judiciary Committee really has the
jurisdiction over the firing of the FBI
director over obstruction of justice so
we should be farther along than we are
and it is truly disappointing that the
House Intelligence Committee is just
hanging of its cleats having not really
run the race hanging up your cleats
having not really run the race you know
disagreed my colleague he doesn't have a
clue what we've done he's not been a
part of any of our investigations so for
him to make that kind of a comment it's
a bit uninformed at best but we're gonna
be continuing this point working with
our colleagues across the aisle to get a
report draft and get their information
in there that they want to to get a
report out the American people the
ranking member your colleague Adam
Schiff has complained long and loud
about a number of people for me that the
Trump campaign or the Trump White House
current or former not answering
questions claiming privilege did you
lose anything by not being able to have
those questions answered we don't
believe so through the it reads I sat
through and those folks I believe we got
the information that was relevant to the
four questions that we're trying to
answer and so we'll go with it you know
it's not surprising that folks would
disagree who wanted to continue this
investigation there may be some on the
Democratic side that never want this to
come to a conclusion because they sense
it has some sort of advantage to them to
keep these keep this wound open we
believe it's important
move forward we've got elections coming
up the primary seasons already started
now we've got important things to
discuss with Mexican people about
protecting our elective process
congressmen Conaway thanks for coming in
and sharing the findings John thank you
for Evian thank you